في تطورات الفيرسي كورونا فتحت الصين
حدودها بعد مضيف ثلاث سنوات على القيود
التي فرضتها بسبب الجائحه وتبقى من القرار
الجديد لن تضطر رحلات الدوليه المتجهه الى
بيجين للدخول عبر النقاط التي كانت محدده
مسبقا لكنها اكدت انه يتعين على القادمين
الى الصين اظهار اختبار سلبي لفايرسي
كورونا خلال يومين من موعد الوصول
واستانفتهم كونج رحلتها مع الصين بعد
تخفيف القيود المفروضه بسبب رائحه كورونا
حيث توفد الاف المسافرين منهم كونج عبر
النقاط الحدوديه التي اغلقت منذ ما يقارب
ثلاث سنوات ولا يزال يتعين على القديمنا
منهم كونج على غرار كل المسافرين الى
الصين اظهار اختبار سلبي نتيجه لفيروس
كورولا خلال يومين قبل موعد الوصول